hi there reject nation I'm Greg Elbe
John Humphrey Andrew Gordon follow
Andrew Gordon on the movie source
channel thanks for showing up here or 30
in the morning with us it's what alarm
clocks are from America we got the
reaction up for endgame trailer number
two like we said in that video we wanted
to do a breakdown of the trailer do our
best to do this you know because
oftentimes we do a reaction you don't
have time to dissect every single moment
or so I tried in that trailer and you
stopped me I had to man we need
something for this video you're about to
like I saw it I can feel you I felt you
going like oh it's about to spit before
we go into this you know you got to keep
a couple things in mind Russo brothers
they're known to manipulate their
trailers alright yeah there's a couple
of key moments here where I'm like I
wonder if this is actually the character
here you know like there's a couple of
moments like that we do want to mention
- we are gonna make some predictions in
this video it's not for sure gonna be
we're probably gonna be wrong on most of
the stuff but just in case we are right
potential spoiler warnings yeah I'm
warned and I am gonna spoil a lot yeah
as he saw it early brothers are gonna
kill us even though they say 'no exactly
Oh completely accurate - the comic I
reread the last half of this Infinity
Gauntlet comic book last night so
there's like one specific moment in this
chair that really stood out to me as
like oh my god I bet that's omajin or at
least in reference there's a moment that
you know is in our thumbnail for the
reaction so yeah let's go into this so
at the beginning of the trailer all
three of us really like the whole black
and white but with the red symbolism
I've heard a couple of theories as to
what that can represent the blood the
loss of life or the reality stone
perhaps our collective passion for the
MC yes because it is the ten and the
Marvel ten year logo the it's red as
well but red has been their logo color
for so long - it also be in remembrance
for Stanley as well for the film that's
being advertised as the culmination like
then the real culmination of it all they
seem to really be honing in on that
especially with their marketing as you
send the reaction it makes for a good
way to not know footage as well but also
remind you
like know this shit's coming full circle
this time around stakes so an Ironman
saying you know I fought my way out of
that cave he's saying that whole speech
that became Iron Man he's talking about
how he realized he was in love with
pepper and that shot from Iron Man 3
once she's holding the helmet up that
could be a foreshadowing moment though
because there was a leaked photo like we
said there might be spoilers in here
there was a leaked photo online pepper
with a green screen behind her but she
was wearing an iron man like suit I know
in the comic books she does eventually
rock a suit it's like the rescue suit
the rescue you yeah I mean he's talking
about rescue in the first trailer that
could be in reference to that as well I
feel like they are foreshadowing that in
these trailers foreshadowing and the MCU
wow I've never already happened not in
their movies especially yeah I was kind
of wondering with you guys I know we're
gonna talk more about this in a second
but at the end when you see nebula and
Iron Man back in the quantum realm suits
it's like we all know that you're gonna
meet up we all want that scene to wear
cap and Iron Man reunite after the
events of Civil War because we still
haven't had that moment but do you guys
think that kind of minimizes the effect
of that situation especially because you
do see it in that even though we all
know it's gonna happen do you think it
minimizes the effect that all by seeing
in the trailer I thought they were gonna
be in space the whole movie never get
back story is really a quiet
introspective journey [ __ ] I am NOT
gonna lie to you though I would pay to
see a movie where Robert Downey jr.
nebula or stuck in space for a whole two
and half hours I'd be down to watch that
two-lane car passed away yeah in space
what I like too is that because in the
first Avengers trailer when cap is
talking about this is gonna work because
I don't know what I'm gonna do if it
doesn't he's holding a photo of Peggy
Carter Sam and then and here they use a
whole quote from Peggy where she says
the world has changed none of us can go
back the best we could do is start over
they do have the line in here to wear
cap is talking about how some people
move on not us could be specifically
referencing the inspiration from that
line from Peggy Carter actually well it
could just be referencing what's
happening to the MCU overall you know
this is a turning point this is the
start of a new phase this is the handing
over of the guard to new blood and stuff
like that and on top of that just I've
noticed you that they've caps me wearing
a couple different suits from the first
video cuz and that quote you just
mentioned where I don't know what I'm
gonna do if it doesn't work he's that's
the stealth suit from Captain America
Winter Soldier before he changes back
into the First Avenger suit and then we
see a shot of him wearing you say the og
wearing those looks like it was the
First Avenger yeah or it's either that
one or it's the Civil War capped and age
of Ultron it's one of those two but
again we've seen multiple shots of him
wearing different suits so and obviously
there's going to be some time you know
they're gonna be traveling the pass
possibly we'll use using the quantum
roam time vortexes so different points
in the past might be wearing that's
specifically like the Battle of New York
and the first of it there could just be
two caps what I'm really curious about
is how which suits are gonna match with
the beard versus the cleaner question
that's the question and then later shot
you do see Hawkeye and his training as
daughterís we see is Tom Cruise in The
Last Samurai
when Hawkeye is training I'm assuming
Lyla I love Daniel baby
Lyla looked like 15 years younger now
I'm exaggerating but she's definitely a
lot more grown-up here and I know in the
comics that a black ops team does kill
Clint's family which leads are down the
path to becoming Ronin in this one I
imagine it's the decimation effect or
maybe they'll do some type of maybe it's
a decimation
takes up most of the family I don't
think LYLAS in the comics I'm pretty
sure she's at different characters
expanding on the shop before where a
hawk or Ronin is turning his head and he
sees a black widow in this mode
yeah they hold hands here and there's
even a later shot where he's consoling
her and puts his
and on her shoulder and I really like
that because they have history and I
feel like The Avengers movies is where
you feel for their history you know like
Civil War you know like a joke about her
you get a hint about it rooster friends
you know then also there's the line in
the first Avengers movie just like
Budapest right you and I remember
Budapest very differently it seems like
in this specific installment though will
be the most heart we get from their
relationship because it was gone yeah
well in the first Avengers movie he's
you know manipulated mind controlled and
the second one it's kind of there and
this one it looks like it's gonna be a
really crucial element to both of their
journeys in this movie yeah well I like
that they're keeping their friendship as
a thematic you know element because
movies yeah yeah I don't know I think
it's really nice to have you know a
friendship like that like a platonic
it's a guy in a girl in there I have
such a strong bond and I don't know it
always makes me feel warm when they
actually bother with it so I hope they
use it here and there has to be some
type of time jump here within the movie
itself because the hairs they like you
especially notice it there's a montage
everybody dies their hair yeah let's go
to the barber ship Tenenbaums you know
he's gonna scissors needle and they've
seen them all in the barber shop just
can't be a little like guys that's my
favorite basketball team but half the
team was decimated so I can't really
watch the board say more I know this
movie will probably pick up a little bit
after the events of infinity war but it
seems like even in the movie itself
there'll be a bit of a time jump as well
I wonder if the opening scene might
actually be the moment were with Hawkeye
and his daughter that would actually
make the most sense I think to like
establish it I mentioned this in the
reaction a big part of why I'm so
excited for this movie of why I get so
pumped when I watch these trailers that
he's not lying
he's even though there's a lot of
bleakness in this trailer I'm a big fan
of action movies where it feels insanely
personal and that's one of the things I
loved about infinity war was it's
personal and it be in evolves into
something so much more personal by the
end but for a lot of the film you do
feel like yeah it's you know it's
another Avengers adventure movie that
feels a lot more personal than usual but
by the time it ends though you're like
oh [ __ ] this is so personal and having
that be the setup for this one with a
real threat level from the get-go of
that much personal intensity to death
being a real threat here that's what
gets me so excited the bleakness expulse
me up actually well yeah because the
last movie really establishes that level
of stakes too because for us as viewers
it takes an experience that we can
usually walk into and go oh yeah they're
gonna triumph and it really shows us how
we can lose yeah not related to what you
two just said I just had this train
thought so I'm gonna say it it's for
children were killed in the last movie
Eponine mom Proxima midnight and the big
guy who we can't call the black door
because we got to be PC on here we saw
Corvus glaive gets stabbed through the
chest you know from vision but if you
remember from the comics the glaive
which is that kind of sword that you
know vision you know slam through his
chest if that is not destroyed it does
not matter if you kill Corvus glaive he
will still come back so I'm wondering if
they are gonna take that comic book and
Suresh because they clearly did not
destroy the glaive and I've seen
infinity Wars so many times now they
clearly did not destroy that clay so is
Corvis gonna be back in this film like
work with Thanos on them going to the
time vortexes make you know things
unhappen you know people who die or
whatever but I still think Corvus glaive
is going to be in this even though you
got stabbed in the chest but I hope so I
gotta say also on the trailer editing of
this the shot were Falcon decimates away
in front of it makes it look like it's
fern of a koi a because it's not like
that in infinity yeah right and back
from and he didn't see it because like
Panther disappears from a koi yet and
there's no koi yeh in any of these
trailers obviously a koi a did survive
the decimation but they did teaser here
I'm wondering like this you're gonna
show when she shows up what element is
she gonna play the show were here you
got to imagine they're gonna be doing
that she's gonna show up with two
Chitauri on chains jaws removed as if
they're like her minions for travelling
as a nomadic warrior throughout new
earth yeah she's gonna have a samurai
sword and long dreadlocks now I love the
editing of the way they've been doing
the trailers because I line the cat says
we see that line in the Super Bowl spot
where it looks like it's in that group
therapy session that he's in but you see
here that it's actually HM well yeah
they say it's a conversation with
something Sparling joke's on the people
that shot when Scott Lane is looking at
signs of the decimation I've heard
theory is that that final moment in the
first Avengers trailer could be him kind
of time traveling around already that's
why cap is like is this an old footage
because I saw some breakdown where it
said that look like in 1983 was on the
screen there higher and this time vortex
and uh and a man at the wasp so here he
could have been caught up I just look
how lost he looks and also it keeps
saying missing on there you know and
Tony P Henderson you know to me
Paul Rudd looked clueless yes you might
say he is going to anchor many but
efforts to save Love You Man bro
us youtubers under Robo no let's see you
guys later on the mange it says missing
on there and so I imagine that in this
sort of post-apocalyptic kind of world
that not everyone was show there are
people who probably just considered
missing because someone probably didn't
see them perhaps people have been
greatly divided because he yeah like we
haven't seen their social media posts in
three weeks where are they well and when
you just think about how big and
intricate the network of a society is
you know I would imagine that it's
entirely possible as well for people to
just go kind of missing
yeah and I got imagines that thing works
like if you haven't seen your loved one
they're probably gone but who knows and
getting on the technical side John Gregg
and I were kind of talking about this
like what happened to the people let's
say you're on an airplane and the pilots
got decimated in the snap like obviously
the whole planes gonna go down so it's
like it could be even more than I mean I
get that's more on the technical side
but imagine if you're at the dentist say
is like halfway Blake into a surgery
with you and then the dentist just
disappears I would say I want the
opening of this movie to be that much
down we've got people in bad sued we can
even get Corbin's from events Bernsen
back and have him plays role as the
dentist and just having like about to
kill someone
I've been down for that and you get that
shot that's expanding on the Super Bowl
a sequence where Hawkeye is looking up
at something it's all red and then it
looks like what follows that moment is a
giant explosion in that scene we have no
solid theories as to where he smaller -
it could be the same moment from where
we see ant-man rocket war machine and
cap or it could be the scene right
before we see Ronan and and Black Widow
reunite not sure what's the make of it
doesn't really matter we'll find out
soon now my favorite I think all of our
favorite shot and for me it's a real
personal favor shot is that moment where
cap is struggling to you good first you
see the shield shot and then you see the
shot of him just really having a hard
time that's my one of my favorite
moments in the Infinity Gauntlet comic
book is when cap decides to take a stand
and have a impossible fight with Thanos
where it's a one-on-one fight moment
with him and it feel like that specific
moment is in reference to it see and
then this could be a spoiler it's not
exactly 100 integrity the Infinity
Gauntlet company in the comic though he
does destroy a cap shield in that moment
which would be baggage all of it
terrified yeah because no one able to
break that shield you know so if he
breaks that in the comics he breaks that
shield and I think he kills him he kind
of just hit so many knocks out it looks
like he's dead in the comics I'd be
surprised they were just showing us that
moment where it's like oh that's what he
does but then again they deal with Loki
an infinity war visually - it kind of
reminded me even though obviously
completely from that is what you just
mentioned it kind of reminded me from
infinity war when he's holding the
gauntlet he's he's struggling making
that face you know what I mean yeah kind
of hurt but a little bit back to that -
for me - yeah both of these head
campaigns have caps struggling yeah
which is I mean which does fill you with
dread because he is the beacon of the
Avengers so to see him in such anguish
and the sequences shop we were kind of
going back and forth on what we think
that could be I know in the Super Bowl
spot you do have that moment where Ant
Man and war machine are suiting up it
looks like it's all in the same sequence
right there - Mia read that it's not on
earth to me it read that it's probably
on some type of planet where they're
trying to fight Thanos they must be
fighting fan
in that moment into a time vortex or
somewhere in the ass or maybe they
attacked the Avengers facility because
you were pointing out like the items
that ant-man's hoppin around you see
like the number two pencil yeah there's
like a regular pencil there's like a
mechanical pencil or a pen or something
there's a roll of tape there's like a
dangling headphone jack like some office
items yeah this makes me wonder all
kinds of things partly like you know
because we have the time travel element
it's like and Marvel is made it clear
that they are willing to change things
up for their movies I would imagine it's
not earth because especially in those
shots with Tony and nebula it looks like
someplace else but maybe I don't know
maybe major destroy agent finders earth
before they even go back in time to be
more trailer manipulation in the
background warning or yeah I mean
because you gotta imagine those were
shot on green screens thing well
anything isn't happy and then we got a
clear shot of rocket in the 2008
guardians of the galaxy comics soon but
at the same time I'm kind of wondering
if that is a trailer manipulation shot
on there and of whose shoulder he's
standing on it at war machine yes and
warmer so it would be cool if that if
it's them together because I like this
evolution of rocket who's like willing
to work with people more often now but I
kind of get the impression there's
something about that shot as cool as it
is there's something about that shot
where I'm like this looks like it could
be a manipulation shop yeah I mean it is
one of the few shots in this trailer
that is overtly like oh cool yeah it's
really on Peter Dinklage's shoulder it's
Peter Dinklage yeah Howard the Duck and
also that moment when nebula in the
Infinity Gauntlet comic when she does
eventually take the glove off Thanos
she's kind of just all dead she seems
like not a threat at all she's nothing
like this here she's just sort of walks
over and grabs the Goblin off again it's
not gonna be I don't think any of that's
gonna happen I don't think she's gonna
get the garland really I think but I do
think it's gonna kill him and my thing I
mean if anyone who's all live deserves
to do it with her again for me this is
me I'm sure many of you felt this way
the mole and I had been said this to you
probably don't remember but when we saw
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 I said to
Greg right his Nebula was spilling that
speech to James Gunn's brother Shawn
every time I would lose to Gamora my
father would replace a part of my body
with a you know and a robotic pardon and
then he's like
I just meant get a purse or something
like that makes me but I turned to Greg
right then I'm like she's killing Panos
we shall see I'm gonna be wrong guys I
think it went and there's a slide in
this trailer that I'm sure a lot of
people are gonna be quoting yeah tattoos
oh yes tagging because especially with
all like the talk of more sacrifices to
be had some potential finite deaths in
the MCU with some of these characters
whether they're cutting around your
whatever it takes
never takes whatever it takes caps say
whatever it takes black widow says it
Iron Man says Richard the Russo brothers
put it on their Twitter - I could be
wrong I think they put I think they did
whatever it takes whatever I'm kind of
wondering is the action in the movie I
know in the first trailer it's more
apparent that an infinity war when
they're all saying Nick Fury's lied at
the beginning of that if it were it that
was like like obviously that's not gonna
be in the movie but this one I'm kind of
wondering is that a scene where it's
kind of like a heroic moment where
they're all like in a group whatever
like before they go to the cornfield oh
yeah they did show Cap'n like one of
those chefs right as he's you know in
the Infinity Gauntlet as you mentioned
so yeah I could imagine that is one of
those scenes where everybody looks
around and there's conferring with each
other if you're in I'm in or it could be
one of those things where only one
person actually says it in the cut of
the movie and also to the reason we
think it could be cap as well like is
because there's that line in infinity
where again a lot of foreshadowing is we
don't trade lives or sacrifice from one
another or something like that and then
you said like cap did that obviously in
the first Avengers so it kind of just
Hartman's back and forth to cap cap and
then of course the major shot where all
the Avengers are rockin quantum suits
I'm kind of curious if that is a spoiler
if Iron Man and nebula they're both
there or maybe because in that one shot
of that you get that's in both trailers
trailer one and two before you before
they did the close-up on them in the
quantum systems trailer one trailer two
here but then the Super Bowl spot
there's silhouettes of just a few in the
Iron Man and nebula are not there
correct that for sure yeah silhouette
that for sure is trailer manipulation
right there so I'm wondering if some of
the people actually not there and
they're making it look like they're
there and the other thing I noticed you
in the quantum suits is that they all
have the Avengers symbol on them
which I thought was really dope they
should have put hp4 hank pym yeah hank
pym created the avenger simply and then
of course the last moment that like this
one with the cat Marvel and Thor a big
debate a big talk has been his cat
Marvel even stronger than Thor you know
like the wicker the way they're building
her up can't she be stronger than Thor
is even more established of time jumps
because you do see Black Widow again
there where she does have the short
blonde hair so I imagine that scene
probably picks up right after and this
is a spoiler that picks up right after
the mid credits moments probably the
next day or something like that that you
see in the movie Captain Marvel I don't
want to get into the bait of Captain
Marvel stronger than Thor I'll just say
this she's obviously beyond strong when
she goes binary or was able to stop an
infinity Gatlin with all six stones with
Stormbreaker he's pretty damn strong to
me yeah yo peace that's a fun debate to
have though I guess but I think what
storm breakers basically the strongest
ever but that is me mostly I just find
it very amusing that looking at the
comments on this trailer and in the
hearing the comments after Captain
Marvel that most everybody likes her
performance in those two one-line
sequences then they do I mean despite
even though like I overall thought she
was just fine I like to perform it's
more the second time around I feel like
a lot of that comes out to the direction
of Captain Marvel you just watch those
videos to understand more what I mean no
we check is more but I do think that
watching her bond with a team or
interact with them is gonna be a
highlight of history but you have a big
fear that you were telling me about
before his trailer been dropped
yes and I'm as usual I'm probably gonna
be wrong about this but again it's just
a little prediction Theory I can't I
thought about just more I think about
this movie so I kind of feel like this
movie is gonna be a little bit of an
homage to Back to the Future Part 2
Marty McFly and Doc Brown need to travel
back to 1955 to prevent the alternate
1985 where Biff Tannen is rich he's
powerful and physically emotionally
abuses in that alternate despicable
future that Marty and Doc Brown come to
an Einstein come to be in and they need
to go back like I said to 1955 to go and
destroy the the gray sports Almanac to
prevent that alternate 1985 from
happening whereas in the Avengers
infinity war they're going to be using
ant-man's quantum realm time board
quantum realm technology to get into the
time vortexes going to you know points
in the past try and steal those Infinity
stones before Thanos even got them so
that when they return to 2019 everything
will be instantly erased in terms of no
pun intended in terms of what Thanos did
because he never had these stones
because they took him in the past and
again you harping that back to again
what happened in Back to the Future Part
two well I look at it this way
Doc Brown and Marty McFly are the
Avengers Thanos is Biff you also have
the decimation where the snapping were
half the people are destroying the
universe whereas George McFly was
murdered you have quantum realm time
vortexes where the DeLorean the time
machine I see a lot of similarities I'm
sure it might be more complicated that
there might be parallel universes and
all that other stuff that gets a little
overly complicated but be interesting to
see if this is a homage to Back to the
Future Part two so we'll have to wait
and see and not probably be wrong in
that what do you guys think
well you know how they're introducing
Ronan right it's on a hoverboard chase
yeah yeah he starts out over water and
then like they're like oh so they were
right in that prediction guys in 89
hoverboards do exist in 2019 just four
years off guys 2015 23 males
some people find like the whole
time-traveling thing to prevent it could
be a bit of a cop-out but you know in
the comic Nebula when she does take the
gauntlet she has something where she's
like take him back to how it was 24
hours ago and undoes it and a lot of
people most people don't know what
occurred yeah so I mean it would be
comics accurate for the most part if
they did that what else can you do like
to get everybody banned I like to John
said like so are all the Avengers going
to all these points in time or are they
separating it's not like okay we're
gonna go after the reality stone at this
point in time a few Avengers then some
of the other ones we're gonna go after
the time stone at this time with a few
Avengers that'd be interesting to see
because like Ben will go into six
different points all at once
now obviously would still be interesting
it would kind of drag a little too but I
mean we'll see what happens with that
but I mean infinity war was no stranger
to splitting up the team into fighting
it up and having even the posters had
different groupings and characters and
it's like if you're going to steal one
stone you ought to steal them all and
yeah you could have
maybe they must save yondu he's Mary
Poppins y'all alright guys are there any
theories that we might have missed or
anything in this video really breezed
off faster heads you know yeah you know
what the sentence I'm trying to say
comment below
well you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and check us on patreon we got a
lot of goodies over there and also and
you're on the movie source channel
thanks for being here buddy see you guys
soon